good mother puts her daughter's needs
before her own a good mother makes good
choices and she doesn't drag a child
from town to Town School to school you
didn't make good choices you had good
choices options that being rich and
white and entitled gave you that's the
difference between oh that is so good
that is Kerry Washington and Reese
Witherspoon in the hit TV series little
fires everywhere you might have heard
about it it's about two mothers from
very different backgrounds it's adapted
from the best-selling novel by author
Celeste INC now critics are calling her
new novel her most powerful work to date
our missing Hearts tells a story about
Chinese American family in a dystopian
near future in the book a boy named Bird
searches for his mother a poet who was
on the Run first on CBS morning's
Celestine joins us right now good
morning how you doing good morning thank
you so much for having me on of course
so our missing Hearts is a bit of a
departure for you
um was it difficult to write a darker
book well it did feel like I was doing
something new as you say the book looks
at some dark subjects but I realized
that at the heart of the story it's
really a family story and they're the
things that I always seem to write about
mothers and children how do we raise
children in a world that feels like it's
hard and and how do we hold on to Hope
through all of that the difference is
that it's not the world we live in right
now this second but it's also not not
our world as you write in the back of
the book explain the difference yeah
it's a world that I think is really
governed by fear there's a lot of
distrust of other people and it's a
world in which if you are acting
Un-American your children can be taken
away and so it's a world in which I
think the characters have to make some
really hard choices and again figure out
how they're going to raise their
children to still survive in this world
you'd write about anti-asian violence in
this book talk about you know how
difficult that was is you started
writing this book in 2016 with sort of a
different direction but you're watching
the world you're watching politics and
all of these events that are informing
the story in the end exactly
um it always started with the mother-son
story for me I am a mother myself and I
always think a lot about family and
parents but as the world outside my
office started to get really dark it
started to feel strange to not put that
on the page and kind of crept into the
book and so part of this book was me
working through the questions I was
asking myself as a parent you know how
do I tell my kid like okay things seem
hard but we're going to get through this
and we can still try and make the world
better how important was it though to do
it through your perspective that became
a really big part of it especially after
the the outbreak of covid started and we
started seeing a huge rise in anti-asian
hate growing up as a chinese-american
I'm from Cleveland but I think I've
known my whole life that I I'm seen as
other by other people and the way other
people see me is not the way I know
myself to be inside and seeing that play
out on the news with Asian people just
being attacked on the street in the
middle of the day I think really made it
important for me to to try and talk
about about some of that in the book
that along with coming out of the
pandemic you know did you ever struggle
with hope because I'm always curious
when an author writes about something
and you take away as a reader something
as powerful as hope
is there struggles within the author's
own life they're actually
thinking to myself you know if I go to
med school and I'd become a doctor maybe
I could be in the hospital helping
people right like there's something
tangible you could do right and as a
writer what what am I doing am I am I
helping the world at all
but I realized one of the things that
was getting me through was reading my
favorite poems listening to music that I
love watching movies that I love that
reminded me of sort of what the world
could be that the world wasn't always
like this it's not always going to be
like this like we can make a difference
and I think that's one of the things art
can do it can give us hope for the
future it can be a source of Solace a
source of good discomfort that makes you
think about what you don't want to
happen you've got a big old fat thank
you in the back of the book to your mom
and your sister for putting up for what
you call this whole creative writing
thing it's turning out pretty well right
it is I think so I come from a family of
scientists my mom is a chemist my dad
was a physicist my sister's an engineer
and I turned out to be a writer and I
think they're they've been really
supportive in this even though I think
they don't always understand what I'm
doing and I'm so grateful for that
writing great books
thank you so much our missing Hearts is
on sale right now